CBS News science and futurists
contributor Michio Kaku is a physics
professor at the City University of New
York and joins us at the table we know
it's not good if you're sitting at the
table Michio Kaku but we are glad you're
here so we've started getting calls here
yesterday call Los Angeles a big
earthquake there six point four so put
it in perspective for us how bad how big
is it
well it's big enough to cause tremendous
damage the Northridge earthquake which
is at six point seven just a little bit
higher in magnitude but it hit a
populated area the good news is this
took place they're relatively unpopular
the area of the Mojave Desert about a
hundred miles away from the main San
Andreas Fault that's the good news the
bad news however is that the probability
of a big one hasn't changed at all you
said we're long overdue long overdue
we're playing Russian roulette with
Mother Nature you realize that's the
last big earthquake to hit the LA
segment of the San Andreas Fault
was get this 1680 that's over 300 years
ago but the cycle time for breaks and
earthquakes on the San Andreas Fault is
a hundred and thirty years so we are way
overdue in any given year the
probability of the big one is 3% in any
given year think about that that's
pretty high when we're talking about
earthquakes so here's a question for you
how good are we at predicting whether
this earthquake is going to come
tomorrow or the next day of the day
after look I'll be blunt
it's voodoo black magic trying to
predict when an earthquake is gonna take
place the Japanese are the world's
leader in this area and they can only
predict an earthquake perhaps maybe a
few seconds to a minute before it
actually hits so we are children when it
comes to understanding earthquake
prediction all we know are probabilities
in 30 years time 30 years the
probability of the big one is about a
hundred percent however we will see the
big ones inevitable it's gonna happen
it's a law of physics we keep hearing
aftershocks aftershocks aftershocks how
worried should people be there oh well
we've had over a hundred aftershocks so
far and there
to continue for weeks on end but the big
aftershocks are largely taking place now
perhaps an aftershock a 5.0 so the
safest way to deal with this is what to
move LA the next 30 years get on the web
learned about things things you can do
for the family talk to your family talk
to your kids loved ones about what to do
stock up on food water in case of an
emergency go have an escape route talk
to your kids about an escape route get
hooked up to the internet or our radio
whatever be prepared basically because
it will happen
professor Kaku thank you so much for
that information